good day las vegas for most of us living
on our own is a rite of passage becoming
part of becoming an adult but for many
in our special needs community it's a
goal that's
just out of reach next week opportunity
village will unveil its attempt to help
adults with disabilities live on their
own i got a sneak peek and i wasn't the
only one
i remember when this was just a dirt lot
for corey gerhart the dream has come
true
now there's houses been killed today he
saw his new home for the first time
the first time he'll live on his own i
was telling my mom that i wanted to live
on my own and stuff for a long time and
now i'm actually going to live in this
nice
this nice apartment
and stuff so oh man
a little overwhelming yeah gerhart is
one of the first tenants at betty's
village
it's the first housing project built by
opportunity village
the adults with special needs it employs
can now live independently
gerhard's mother is i'm speechless sort
of ready to let him leave
so beautiful you've been accepted to
live in betty's village
70 adults most with special needs will
live here
for many it'll be their first time in a
home of their own everyone needs to have
a little bit of independence
rhiannon massio is responsible for
running betty's village
people with disabilities can do it on
their own and you just have to give them
that opportunity
and with the right supports in place i
mean you can do whatever you want
ov will have staff on site to help the
tenants
there's a gym a pool just like any other
apartment complex
this is a community the next chapter in
my life
is happening corey and his mother are
still adjusting
then it hit me how i'm going to feel
with him not being there
and i it took my breath away
but he's just a phone call away that's
actually my house
corey can i give you a hug sure this is
like seeing my house
i'm so excited welcome home dude
very exciting for for cory and all the
tenants there opportunity village is
holding a grand opening for the 35
million dollar complex next week
tenants will start moving in soon
afterwards and the non-profit says it is
considering building more housing units
like this for its clients
in the future we've seen that progress
alex from day one we were out there when
it was a dirt lot two years ago
we followed the process right along and
very happy for cory and all the folks
who are going to get to live there
because
living independently is so important i
remember
you showing us that i know you followed
it uh yeah how exciting and that is so
cool to see john you did a great job
with that
yeah it's a nice it's a nice complex too
beautiful that's beautiful
all right that is great stuff good job